something of an environmental disaster
happening out here and nobody seems to
know it's happening a major incident was
declared on Sunday after around 20 000
liters of reservoir fluid leaked from a
pipeline Dorset the fluid made up of 85
water and 15 oil came from our Bay into
poor Harbor its tidal so the leaked oil
will have been moving into surrounding
Waters
the witch Farm onshore oil field is the
largest in Western Europe it's operated
by parenko the main Gathering station is
here with crude oil extracted for more
than 10 well sites the pipelines
connecting them run around two to three
meters Underground
Sky News understands the leak occurred
here next to Well site D bubbling water
was spotted indicating oil was rising
from below ground
the view from the Gathering station
across the harbor shows the area
immediately affected by The Spill on the
far side two miles from the League this
video is filmed from hamworthy Park and
this was taken at Pool Key also on the
other side of the harbor at the leaked
location as part of the cleanup
operation a floating skimmer is being
used to extract the oil from the surface
it's being pumped into this portable
tank and extracted by the tanker
Downstream closer to Paul Harbor booms
are being used to stop the spread
further and contain the spill
people are being told to stay out of the
water and while the full environmental
impact is not yet known the rspb says
oil birds have been spotted around the
harbor this shell duct was showing signs
of contamination at lichit Bay more than
four miles from the leak as the oil
disappears from the surface of the water
it doesn't mean it's gone some of it
will have been evaporated but some of it
will get incorporated into the water
column and incorporated into the muddy
sediments of Pearl Harbor that's at the
very base of the food chain and those
kind of particles could stay there for
months years even and and be a kind of
slow release poisonous Time Bomb back
into the food chain that's our real big
concern we don't know yet exactly how
the leak happened but the government
says a full investigation will take
place